FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello and
welcome to today's talk
at Google.
We're incredibly pleased
to host David Burkus, who
is the author of "The
Myths of Creativity",
"The Truth About How Innovative
Companies and People Generate
Great Ideas".
David is a contributing writer
for "Forbes" and "Psychology
Today", and has
also been featured
in "Fast Company, Inc.",
"Bloomberg Business Week",
"Financial Times", and
even on "CBS This Morning".
So I'm sure that you're
all excited to spend time
with him over the
next 40, 45 minutes.
He'll be sharing a little bit
of insight about his book,
and then opening
up to questions.
So without further
to do, over to you.
DAVID BURKUS: So,
thank you, thank you.
Yeah, the CBS
thing, it was cool.
I saw a couple people
nod, there, quite cool.
Unfortunately, I was on
the Saturday edition.
So I did not get to
meet Charlie Rose.
But life goal for the next book.
So I want to talk to you
a bit about this book now.
And really I want
to tell you a bit
about the story of a
realization that I had.
The weird thing
about writing a book
is you learn things
after you publish it.
After you send it
to the publisher
people then start
discussing you.
And you realize that, I set
out to write a business book,
or I thought I was
writing a business book.
And I found I've written a book
that has I hope a little bit
broader implications for
how we rethink things.
And it's this one sentence
that I didn't really
figure out until
after I had published,
which was, the stories we
tell ourselves are true,
even if they're not true.
So the things that
we tell ourselves
are true even if
they're totally false,
even if they have
no basis in reality.
Because if we tell it
to ourselves enough
we eventually start
to believe it.
And there's a
psychological principle
called confirmation
bias that confirms this.
Confirmation bias that
confirms this, that's funny.
What confirmation
bias essentially does
is it says that you
filter out things
that don't conform to
what you already believe.
And you willfully
seek out things
that will conform to
what you already believe.
It will confirm your beliefs.
So, you probably
have realized this.
If you've ever been
car shopping you
have found confirmation
bias at work, right.
Who has been car
shopping recently?
And what kind of car
did you decide on?
AUDIENCE: A Ram 1500.
DAVID BURKUS: A Ram 1500.
How many RAM 1500s did you see
shortly after you bought it?
AUDIENCE: Oh, a lot.
DAVID BURKUS: They're all
over the place, right?
And it's not like
anything changed, I mean,
unless you decided to drive
through Texas after you bought
it.
It's not like anything changed.
It's still a Ram 1500.
There were still just as
many on the street as before.
But your mind is drawing
attention and flagging
and signaling you
when it's there.
And interestingly, the things
that you chose not to buy,
it sort of just fades
to the background.
Now if you really, really want
to get a taste of this wait
until this fall, because we have
an election season coming up.
And this is when
confirmation bias
is on display for
the world to see.
So if you still don't believe
in the Ram 1500 example,
get into a political argument
with someone who thinks
differently than you on some
social network, via Twitter,
Google+, Facebook, whatever.
It has to be a social
network because it
has to be asynchronous.
You have to give them time to
find some blog that supports
their world view and
then come back to you.
So it can't be a face to face
discussion because then it'll
be like human and you'll
find common ground.
We don't want that.
We're showing
confirmation bias at work.
But what eventually
happens is the stories
that we tell ourselves become
true because of confirmation
bias.
And this happened in
this case with this book.
I used the term myths
because myths are stories.
And myths are stories
that we make up
to try and explain things that
we can't really explain fully.
And what happens over
time is those myths
become true, even
if they're not true.
So I set out, actually, to
write a leadership book.
I did my Doctoral work on
strategy and leadership.
And I set out
wanting to know, what
is it that the
leaders of amazingly
creative organizations do
that other people don't do.
And it came down to
this idea of stories.
And it really-- the
deep dark secret-- it
wasn't all that much
about the actual leader.
It was just about
what are the stories
that people are
telling themselves.
So we tell a lot of different
stories, lots and lots
of different stories.
One of my favorites is,
if you pay attention
to the way we
describe creativity,
we tell an almost religious
story around creativity.
It almost feels like
it's some religion.
And if you go to certain parts
of the world-- San Francisco,
Austin, Texas, parts of
New York-- creative people
actually look like priests
of some near eastern religion
you've never heard of.
Piercings, tattoos,
things that you're like,
wow, you really could be a
guru on a mountain somewhere.
But you're a barista.
But you know what I mean.
So we talk about it in these
weird, almost religious terms.
And I think we do
that to our detriment.
Because in reality
it's something
that's sort of
accessible to everyone.
So we talk about creativity
like it's a gift from the gods.
We talk about innovation
like it happens in a flash.
In reality it's actually a
little simpler to explain.
I can do it with a picture.
So a woman by the
name of Teresa Amabile
did this amazing
series of research
and came up with what she
calls the Confidential
Model of Creativity.
Which essentially says,
every creative insight
happens when four things
are at play together.
Now I already know
what you're thinking
because I see people's eyes.
There are only four
circles on the slide.
We'll get to that.
So four things essentially
in play, expertise,
creative thinking,
skills, and motivation.
Expertise, you actually
have to know something
about where you want
a creative insight in.
Interestingly enough,
too much expertise
can sometimes be a bad thing.
We'll get to that.
Creative thinking skills.
Do you actually
know the processes,
especially in groups, for coming
up with lots of great ideas?
Or are you just
sort of winging it?
Or are you throwing
yourself in a room
and doing what we call
brainstorming but looks nothing
like what its creator intended?
So creative thinking
skills, I think,
we have a hard time
thinking that expertise,
in particular, and
creative thinking
skills are two
different circles.
Most of the time we use
this term creatives a lot.
We use this term creatives.
We describe advertising
copy as creative copy now.
And what I think is
interesting about that
is that's actually merging
these creative thinking
skills with expertise.
But you can use
creative thinking skills
and, even in fields
of expertise,
that no one would call
creative, like accounting.
Now sometimes you do that at
the detriment of the world.
But, I mean, I use
mint.com every single day.
It's an amazingly
creative product.
So the last one is motivation.
And intrinsic motivation
is generally better
than extrinsic
motivation, things
like bonuses and incentives.
But there are things we can
do to structure and align
those two to actually have
an even more powerful force.
But in general intrinsic
motivation works really well.
It's often been said necessity
is the mother of invention.
I'd say necessity is
the mother innovation.
Why?
Necessity is a really
good intrinsic motivator.
If you have a problem that
desperately needs to be solved,
you have a lot of motivation
to solve said problem.
Now three circles,
four components.
The fourth component is
the social environment.
What is the environment in which
you are actually operating in?
Is it generally supportive
of new and creative ideas?
Does it squelch ideas?
Does it support idea sharing?
Does it support what a friend
of mine calls little bets?
Does it support the idea of
taking lots of little risks,
deferring judgment?
All of these sort of things
help shape a social environment
that can harbor creativity.
And what I think
is interesting is
when I think about the
perfect social environment,
I actually think about a
kindergarten classroom.
Does anyone have
kindergartners or younger kids?
So I have a two-year-old
and a two month old,
which means we're
looking at the beginner
programs-- preschool
programs, working our way up.
And if you go in and
visit a kindergarten,
you'll see a classroom of 25
people and maybe four really,
really frazzled
looking teachers.
But you'll see 25
kids, little people.
All of them are
incredibly creative.
I teach college most
days out of the year,
and when I get a
classroom of 25 students,
if I asked them if they think
they're creative, two of them
will raise their hand.
And both of them are
marketing majors.
That doesn't even
count because they just
think they're giving
me the right answer.
So we go from 25 to two.
And I just think this is
incredibly depressing.
And the reason that we do is
that the social environment
changes.
As you move through life
you become more and more
aware of the fact that not
everyone loves your crazy,
off the wall ideas.
And eventually it becomes easier
to just not bring them up.
You learn that regurgitating the
right answer back to a teacher
is just easier.
And even if you have a
very forward thinking,
progressive school, we
still have a society
that doesn't really value
creative, new ideas.
And we'll talk about
that at the tail end
because I think that's the
most devastating story that we
tell ourselves.
But again, to go with this
idea that the stories we
tell ourselves are
true, there's a lot
of stories I've found
that we tell ourselves
around creative people,
creative companies,
that we use to
discount ourselves.
One of my favorites
is this Eureka story.
And I'm indebted
to a lot of people.
I'm not the first person that's
taken aim at the Eureka story.
One of the most fascinating
examples of this
is Newton and the apple.
How many people have
ever heard the story
of Newton and the apple?
Tell it to me,
Newton and the apple.
So Isaac Newton is sitting
under an apple tree.
What happens?
Apple falls.
Isaac Newton discovers gra-- no.
Does something related
to gravity, right.
Great story.
Great lesson for
aspiring, creative people.
What's the lesson?
Sit under a tree and
wait for stuff to happen.
Now, I can tell you
because I've searched
lots and lots of sources.
The Story is not actually true.
There's a version of the
story very similar to it
that does involve an
apple that has already
hit the ground and Isaac
Newton talking about apples.
But the actual hitting never--
we can't source that story.
Over time, of course,
so Isaac's over here
and he's talking about the
apple falling to the ground.
Over time we retell the story.
And the apple levitates and
Isaac moves closer to it
and eventually we
arrive at this moment.
And it's a good story.
But the lesson is
a terrible one.
I don't have time to
sit under apple trees
and wait for stuff to happen.
But again, if you
remember, myths
are things we tell ourselves
because they sort of feel true
and then the confirmation
bias takes over.
So there is some
truth to the story.
And fortunately a
researcher by the name
of Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi,
whose name is so awesome you
should say it any
time you get a chance.
It's like plus 10 on perceived
IQ if you can say it.
So he did this
amazing study where
he surveyed outstandingly
creative, renowned
creative people in a
variety of different fields.
Essentially he asked
lots of different people
in different fields,
who do you admire?
And then when they sort of
aggregated around a name,
he went out and sought
that person out.
And he just asked them, describe
to me your creative process.
And then he did sort of a
qualitative factor analysis.
And he arrived at,
everybody's creative process,
as he described it, goes through
these five different stages.
So we start out
with preparation.
This is where you're doing
research on the problem.
You're gaining expertise.
And then most people who
have these insights go
into a period of incubation.
So they actually set it aside.
They don't just plow
right through the problem
and try and prepare
and prepare and prepare
until they arrive at a solution.
They take some time off.
They grab a Google bike and
they go for a ride sometimes.
They sit under an
apple tree sometimes.
More often than not they
actually just switch projects.
So while one project
is incubating
they're working on
a different one.
And so sometimes you can
move into the third stage,
which is that insight.
That's the aha moment.
And sometimes it really
does happen directly out
of incubation.
So if you think about
a story like Newton
and the apple, Archimedes
in the bathtub,
I think there probably was
some sort of aha moment.
He was incubating and
then it came to him.
And then gradually over
time the story just
gets better if you
merge those two events.
And we've all had
those moments, right?
We think about it.
My best ideas come to me in
the shower or when I'm jogging
or when I'm doing something
that forces that incubation.
But the thing I think
is really interesting
is you can
deliberately incubate.
And when you get done
with an incubation period
you can deliberately
set back to it.
So research supports
the idea that if you
work on a problem for a
while, then you incubate, then
you return and do something like
a brainstorming or an ideation
technique, you will generate
more and better ideas
because you spent
that time incubating.
So a lot of times I get asked,
great, but how do I do that?
And one of the things
that I've started doing
is, I use email as a
form of incubation.
Because most of the emails
I get are not important.
No offense.
But there are things like, come
to this address at this time.
There are things like, hey
can you confirm this meeting?
They're just little things
that I need to click through.
They're not all that important.
And so I turned on my phone.
I turned off all of my
notifications around email.
My email on my computer does
not automatically update.
It does it when I do it.
And I do it when I need
to take a little break,
when I need to feel
or look productive.
And I need to take a
little bit of a break
and then I need to return
to what I'm working on.
A lot of times
I'll write a piece.
I'll write an article.
Then I'll check email.
Then I'll return to the article.
And then if I have
enough time, if I
didn't wait till
the last minute,
I'll actually print it out,
wait a day, and read it again.
But most of the time it's
write it, email, proof read it.
And I find that it
actually sort of works.
You get newer ways
to phrase things
just by taking that
little bit of time off.
So the question isn't
sit under an apple tree
and wait for
something to happen.
The question is, how can I
structure into my workflow
these actual periods
of incubation?
Now I know what some
people are doing.
They're looking at the fourth
and fifth egg and going,
OK, I already want to
know what those are.
You're the same
people who wanted
to know about the circles.
It's the fourth and fifth egg.
Evaluation, you actually
have to judge whether or not
the idea is good.
And then you have
to elaborate on it.
You have two
externalize it, you have
to bring it out into the world.
All right, so those are
all parts of the process.
But what I think is
really interesting
are stages two and
three because most
of the time those are not
in our normal work rhythm.
We don't actually
work in this idea
of how can I incubate
to get better ideas.
So one of the other
myths that I think
is particularly devastating
is this breed myth.
I joked about it earlier with
my Near Eastern guru barista.
But a lot of times
when we describe
creativity or creative
people we say things like,
oh, they're just
naturally a good whatever.
Which is sort of a damaging
thing for two reasons.
Assuming it were
true would be great.
But it's not.
It's damaging for two reasons
because what you're doing
is you're essentially,
presumably,
taking yourself off the hook.
They're just a natural blank.
I'm not.
Therefore I don't
have to work hard.
The other thing
you're doing is you're
insulting that person because
they worked ridiculously
hard to get to the point
where you called them
a natural, which is
a little insulting.
And we've tried hard to
verify this breed myth.
We've looked at a lot
of different places.
We looked at genetics.
We looked at personality.
Personality essentially, there
are five personality traits,
the Big Five.
And we've tried to
correlate every type
of creative expression
to personality types.
Can't do it.
Actually, one of the Big Five is
called openness to experience.
And that correlates a little
bit, which kind of makes sense.
If you're open to new
ideas and new experiences
you'll be more creative.
That makes sense.
The rest of them
don't correlate.
Introverts are just as creative
as extroverts, All of that.
And the other thing we
tried to do is genetics.
We've looked at studies of
identical and fraternal twins.
We've compared them to each
other, to the baselines.
We can't find
anything that suggests
there's a creativity
gene or creativity
combination of genes.
The way that I describe
it is that nature has yet
to disprove nurture.
But some of us still love to
believe in the idea of nature,
because if somebody
drew an incredibly
creative genetic hand and
I didn't, I'm off the hook.
It's over.
And I think this
also has lessons
for how we perceive
interactions with other people.
Because if we think that some
people are naturally creative,
when we need an idea
who do we gravitate to?
But who do we need
to be gravitating to?
Probably everybody.
And especially the people
who aren't necessarily
experts in that field.
And we'll talk about
that in a little bit.
But first, let's take a pause
around this expertise idea.
One of the things I
think is interesting
is, expertise is sort
of a double edged sword.
Because there's this idea around
originality and creativity,
that creative ideas are
incredibly original.
And so if they're
incredibly original
then you need tons of outsiders
and you need no experts.
And that's not actually true
because almost all new ideas
are combinations of
preexisting ideas.
In no place is this more
aware than in software, right?
It's why we have so many
intellectual property
debates, is where is the line
between copying and infringing
and true original things.
But we see it everywhere.
Anybody in here a
fan of "Star Wars"?
I know, it's sort
of a trick question.
I know, I know.
So "Star Wars" is an incredibly
wonderful combination
of Joseph Campbell's "Hero
with a Thousand Faces"
mono-myth plot line, some
Akira Kurosawa samurai films,
some spaghetti
westerns, and then
a couple "Flash Gordon"
and "Sinbad" movies
thrown in just for good measure.
A lot of people say it this
way, it's a total remix.
And that's OK, because
it's a very original remix.
And it's a very wonderful set.
And it's probably going to be
ruined with the next three.
But whatever, right?
The original one is still
a great combination.
We do this in music
all of the time.
We do this in literature
Mark Twain actually
has this amazing quote
about how the entire
concept of plagiarism
is a farce because no writer
just sat down and wrote
and came up with
anything worth reading.
Instead they studied all
sorts of other works.
And they incorporated
different ideas and techniques.
And their voice is really
just an original combination
of their influences.
Music, I think, at
least has a little bit
of intellectual honesty
around this idea.
Because you can ask a musician,
who are your influences.
And that's code for who did
you listen to a lot of times
and who did you copy.
And that's OK as
long as you copy too.
I teach college so one
source is plagiarism
but multiple, that's
just research.
Right?
So it's cool.
It's about those
sort of combinations.
And what I find is
really interesting
is your brain is actually
wired to do this.
Your brain is
designed to combine.
So your brain is essentially
two fundamental structures.
And this, I have to apologize to
a gentleman named Rex Young who
I borrowed a lot
of insights from
and probably ruined with
gross oversimplifications.
Because he is a neuroscientist
and a neurosurgeon.
And I'm a management
professor and a writer.
So I'm probably not describing
this perfectly but it works.
So your brain essentially
has two things, gray matter
and white matter.
Gray matter is that
spongy stuff we
think about when we
think about thoughts.
It's kind of what
we think about when
we look at an image like this.
And gray matter is where
your thoughts are stored.
But then there's this
other white matter
that's like strings,
almost like wires and cords
that connect all these
different things.
And the way that
your brain works
is by connecting different
areas of gray matter
in different times.
One of the most
interesting things.
If you ever read an
article that says,
oh, we have found the
spot in your brain
responsible for blank.
That will be proven out of
date within the next 10 years.
Because what we're
finding is it's
not about this little area.
It's about combinations
of areas in your brain
that light up because
of the white matter.
And right down the
center of your brain
is a thing called
the corpus callosum.
And it is the thickest area
of white matter in your brain.
And it's the reason we
thought about this left brain,
right brain thing, and why
they need it to communicate.
In truth that whole analogy
is coming out of vogue,
because we're understanding that
this white matter is incredibly
important.
Because the white matter
connects different ideas.
So if the gray matter
is what you think,
the white matter is
almost how you think,
because it's the connections.
Now this is why if you've ever
lost your train of thought
and you try and
redo it, you feel
like you're zig zagging
all over the place.
It's because your brain
doesn't think linear.
It thinks in connections.
This can also be
used to your benefit.
Has anybody watched the
BBC version of "Sherlock"
where the mind palace
idea comes from?
It basically comes from
connecting a visual image
of a house to something
you want to remember.
It's not like it's stored right
next to it in the gray matter.
It's that the white
matter is firing
in that right combination.
So our brain is actually
wired to combine.
And this, I think, has
incredible implications
for you.
What are you consuming?
What are you putting in there?
The more and the more diverse
an amount of gray matter
you're putting in,
and the more you're
experimenting with
original new combinations
of that gray matter, the
more your white matter
could be growing.
We don't actually
know for sure, but we
do think that white
matter is very elastic
and it can grow over
time with expertise.
There's actually a
factual error in my book.
Because before it was published
we thought that Albert
Einstein's brain looked
like everybody else's.
And now we actually know
from some photos of his brain
that was, against his wishes,
taken out of him after he died.
We know from photos that he
had a very, very thick corpus
collasum.
He had an unnatural
amount of white matter.
We don't know if he was born
with it or if he grew it.
The evidence is leaning
towards the idea
that you can actually grow
additional white matter
connections.
You can strengthen
those connections
the more you play around
with combining ideas.
And I think this has
interesting implications
because the other side of the
coin of this expertise thing
is what I actually
call the expert myth.
That when we have a problem
we need to seek out experts.
We need to seek
out people who have
studied the most in their field.
And it's generally a good
idea, but it turns out,
it kind of falls
apart over time.
In essence what happens,
we've studied the careers
of lots of different creative
professionals, playwrights.
There's a joke in
physics that if you
don't do Nobel Prize
winning work by the time
you're 30 you should just
retire at least from research.
And it's kind of funny because
the aforementioned Albert
Einstein won the Nobel Prize
at 46, but for a paper that
was published at 26.
And if you look at the ages
of when publications that
won the Nobel Prize
in physics were,
the ages of the authors
when they were published it,
actually does sort of
aggregate around 30.
There's some truth to the joke.
What's going on
here is that a lot
of times as your expertise
goes up your creative output
can actually go down.
It can look like an inverted U
instead of just an ever rising
screen.
The reason for
this, we think, is
that there's two
parts to an idea.
Remember there's coming
up with the insight.
We call that an ideation rate.
And then there's also evaluating
it and elaborating on that.
We can call that an
elaboration rate.
And as your expertise grows
your ideation rate does go up.
But you're elaboration
rate goes down.
If you study the careers in
a variety of different fields
of creative individuals,
their elaboration rate
goes down over time.
What we think is
essentially happening is,
as they're coming up with ideas
they're coming up with reasons
why not to even bother
trying that idea.
I have all of this expertise so
I know it's not going to work.
It was a fun idea but it's not
going to work and here's why.
And what happens,
I think, in physics
or in any other field like that,
is that you know around that 30
time you just got
out of grad school,
maybe you're in a post-doc.
You're playing around
with new ideas.
You have enough expertise
to be able to come up
with new combinations
of ideas, but not enough
to know it'll never work.
So you test it.
And most of the time
you waste your time.
But every once in a
while you find something
nobody else bothered to test.
And we fly you to Scandinavia.
We give you a metal.
We tell you you're amazing.
We see this all of the time.
And I think this is
not a death sentence.
I don't believe
that this is always,
everyone who has
more expertise always
has their creative
output go down.
Earlier I talked about it.
Expertise is a vital part
of that creative process.
But I think the key is to really
take a look at our influences,
to be someone like Paul Erdos.
Does anyone know
who Paul Erdos is?
Do I have any
mathematicians in the room?
Do You have an Erdos number?
AUDIENCE: No.
DAVID BURKUS: No?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
DAVID BURKUS: No, no, no.
So he and I just had a
conversation, none of you
know what we're talking about.
So let me elaborate.
So an Erdos number
is essentially--
Paul Erdos has more peer review
publications than anyone ever.
We lost count around 1,500.
I have like 12.
He's 1,500.
20 will get your tenure
anywhere you want.
20 in reputable
journals, I should say.
1,500, and the reason was the
man was an intellectual nomad.
So he would study in his field.
And he'd read a
paper by somebody
who was in a different subset.
And he would show up, usually
at the office or sometimes
the house, of the
author of that paper.
And he would say
"my brain is open."
He actually has a biography
written about him.
It's that title,
"My Brain is Open."
And he would move in to
the office, sometimes
into the house, of that person.
And they would work together.
And they would share insights.
They would publish
a couple papers.
Then when he got bored
he would move on again.
So as a result, what you
have is an Erdos number.
What you have is a number
that represents how close you
are to have published
with Paul Erdos.
If you have an Erdos number
one, you published with him.
Two, you published with
someone who published with him.
It's like "Six Degrees of
Kevin Bacon", but for nerds.
Actually, "Six Degrees
of Kevin Bacon"
is also for nerds, just
a different kind of nerd.
So Paul Erdos is sort of
this intellectual nomad
that is constantly
moving around.
And I think we can take
that same approach,
but so often we don't.
Our area of expertise
is really comfortable.
And to admit that we don't
have an expertise somewhere
and begin to study that
is really uncomfortable.
It takes a lot of guts to show
up at the door of someone else.
Especially-- think about
when Paul Erdos arrived
at, oh I don't know,
600 publications.
Think about the
kind of courage it
takes to show up at the office
of somebody with maybe six,
but is doing new stuff.
And to say, I want
to learn from you.
That takes a lot of
courage to admit that like,
I'm not going to play
this comfortable expertise
card that I have
developed over time.
I'm going to take on this
beginner's mindset all over
again.
And I think so often we
don't do that, but we can.
And when we do that, we think
back to the originality myth.
We fill our mind
with more gray matter
and more potential connections.
So we fill our mind
with more raw material
to make combinations out of it.
But it takes a little
bit of courage.
Now, one other way that
you can get really good
in a very short period of
time, like Paul Erdos did,
is by collaborating.
And we live in a world
that's getting better
at collaboration.
But we still tell ourselves what
I call the Lone Creator Story.
We tell ourselves stories
about Thomas Edison.
Thomas Edison invented the---
AUDIENCE: Light bulb.
DAVID BURKUS: Sort of.
Some people are like, I
know it's a trick question
so I'm just going to sit
there and shake my head.
Thomas Edison did.
He was the 22nd or
23rd-- depending
on how you count-- person
to invent the light bulb.
Not bad, not bad, right.
His patent for the
light bulb is actually
called improvements
in electric lights.
So at least he, like,
even he admitted it.
But when we think
about Thomas Edison,
think about his great story
about trying thousands of times
to try out different filaments.
What do you envision?
You picture Thomas Edison alone
in a room somewhere trying out
lots of little different fibers.
But it didn't happen
like that all.
I would submit to you that
Thomas Edison's greatest
invention was actually
his Menlo Park workshop.
He had some of his initial funds
from patents in the telegraph
industry.
And he used that to
build a workshop.
And he invited sort of, Thomas
Edison the Super Friends.
They actually called
themselves the "Muckers",
but that feels
like a dirty word.
So I prefer Thomas Edison
and the Super Friends.
So he invites all
of his friends.
And there are about 15
to 20 people in there
at any given time, working
on lots of different stuff.
Most of them
actually share space
on the patents, their name
space on the patent with Thomas
Edison.
Some of them worked
on their own stuff.
Some of them worked on
projects outside of Edison.
But eventually they
actually kind of found out
that the money was in promoting
this myth of Thomas Edison.
Thomas Edison became
the marketing mouthpiece
of this broader organization.
So they basically found a way
to take advantage of two things.
That we love this lone
creator story and that
we all benefit
from collaboration.
Now sadly the damaging
thing they did
is they propagated
this lone creator myth.
But they're also, if
you know the truth,
they're a testament to this
power of collaboration.
And there's a lot of
researchers that are doing work
showing, OK, so we know
collaboration works.
But how do we do this?
What's the right level
of collaboration?
And one of my
favorites is a study
by two guys, Brian
Uzzi and Jarrett Spiro.
Sorry, not "Uzi",
Uzzi, like the gun.
I had the opportunity to talk
to Brian a little while ago
much more in depth
about his study.
And I learned that I've
been mispronouncing
his name for several years.
But anyway, so their
study looked at Broadway,
because Broadway is an
interesting ecosystem.
To put on a Broadway show
you need six people in you're
senior leadership team.
You need a composer, a
librettist, a lyricist,
a choreographer, a
director, and a producer.
You don't have to know what
all of those things do,
but you need all six of them.
And so at any given
time you can have
a show that has all six people
who have worked together before
or have been totally new.
So you think about red,
all new connections,
and black, all old connections.
So you can have people
who have worked together
on projects before and
be incredibly successful.
They're a super team.
Or you can have a team of
total newbies and strangers.
Now which team would you
want to put your money on?
Let's number them.
So like a scale of one to five.
You want to put
your money on one?
your money on five?
of course not.
You know it's a trick question.
How many people want to
put their money on three?
You're also wrong.
2.6, that's how
you know it's true.
That's how you know they
did proper analysis.
It didn't magically
work out to be three.
2.6.
So what they found is
that in any given year--
essentially this
2.6 number is what
they call small world quotient.
And it's representative of how
many different combinations
in the entire year for
Broadway that they had.
They found that the
best years for Broadway
were when if you graphed this
phenomenon, you arrive at a 2.6
on a scale of one to five.
And so I said earlier
I had a chance
to talk to Brian
about this study.
And one of the questions
that I asked him was,
hey, I've read about
your study before
and I'm not the first
person to write about it.
What's the most frustrating
thing about your study
that people, when they write
about it, that people do?
He said the most
frustrating thing
is that people assume that
means we need 2.6 teams, right.
We need teams that are at 2.6.
Our study is not about that.
Our study is about
something much broader.
Because they didn't
graph the team.
They graphed the network.
So at any given
year for Broadway
we give it a score
of a 2.6 and it's
going to be one of
the better years.
And that's a really
interesting ramification
because here's the thing
if you think about it.
A 2.6 team doesn't stay
a 2.6 team for very long.
You can arrive at building a
2.6 team, a great combination
of old colleagues
and new fresh ideas.
But it won't stay that way.
Eventually it'll
devolve into a one
as people get too experienced.
So the question isn't how do
you find and build a 2.6 team.
It's how do you build a network
that allows a 2.6 team to form,
and then at the
right moment disband.
The beautiful thing
about a Broadway show
is that if it's not "Cats"
it will eventually end.
And those connections,
those ideas, they
will all go to a different show.
So how do you
structure a company,
how do you structure
an organization,
a society that
allows for those connections
to be made and then disband
after the mission is complete?
Now that's an
interesting question.
And we could think about it
at an organizational level.
How do we do this in a company?
But I think much easier
and much more important
is to think about it on
your own individual level.
Are you currently
in a network that
allows for you to form
a 2.6 team around people
when you have a need?
When you need an insight do
you go to the same six people?
Or do you have a
network that allows
you to tap some people who
have no experience in the field
and you don't really even know
all that well and some people
who are old friends?
Most of us, I would argue,
go to the old friends,
go to the people
we know, we trust.
Even inside an organization,
we have a problem,
we go to the person
we know we trust.
Most of us don't
think about, hmm,
I need a 2.6 team around me.
So I think that's a really
interesting question to sort
of audit your own life,
your work life, career with.
Is am I in a network,
a small world network,
as Uzzi and Spiro would call it?
That allows for 2.6 teams to be
formed and disbanded properly.
Now, you can do all
of this stuff right
and still not get it.
The most devastating
story, I talked about this
a little bit earlier, that
I think we tell ourselves,
is the story that I call
the Mousetrap story,
the Mousetrap myth.
And it's taken from this
phrase-- you've all heard it--
if you build a
better mousetrap--
AUDIENCE: The
world will beat a--
DAVID BURKUS: The world will
beat a path to your door.
It's a catchy saying, right.
It's total rubbish,
total rubbish.
The actual mousetrap, right.
So everybody
picture a mousetrap.
Picture a mousetrap.
You're picturing a wooden board,
a metal spring, some cheese,
because there's always
free cheese in a mousetrap.
You're picturing a device
that was invented in 1899.
And every year since then
400 patent applications
come in to the US Patent Office
for new and better, supposedly
better, mousetraps.
Some of them
actually are better.
About 20 of them
have been developed
into commercially
viable products.
You call an exterminator,
they will not
bring spring loaded mousetraps.
You'll buy them.
But they won't bring them.
Maybe it's that expertise
thing, who knows.
But you're picturing something
that was invented in 1899.
Interestingly enough, this
is a total coincidence
but it's a fun one.
In 1899 Charles Duell, the
chief of the US Patent Office,
actually told the government
we should close up shop.
Nothing new is going
to be invented.
Those both happened in 1899.
What's going on here?
Why does this happen?
We live in-- you
live, we live, I
live in the middle
coast of America.
But you all live in a valley
built on the idea of so and so
invented it, didn't develop
it, somebody else did.
I drove by the
Computer History Museum
and it's basically that story.
The same thing happens in
a variety of other fields.
And great ideas get
rejected all the time.
My favorite example,
actually, comes from music.
Anyone a fan of Igor Stravinsky?
I have a two-year-old
son which means
that I watch a lot a
"Little Einsteins."
Which means I am now a
fan of Igor Stravinsky.
Igor Stravinsky's
greatest work was what?
"The Rite of Spring."
How many people have heard
"The Rite of Spring"?
Actually, all of
you, because I'm
going to guess at some
point you watched Fantasia.
And it's in there.
"The Rite of Spring"
is famous not just
for shifting the history of
ballet and musical composition.
It's famous for causing not
one, but two riots on it's
opening night in Paris.
So the show went on.
It was very different from a
traditional ballet at the time.
Some people loved it.
Other people hated
it, loathed it.
And those people
began to argue, didn't
wait to go out for
coffee afterwards
and discuss the pros and cons.
They started arguing while
the show was going on.
Arguments turned
into shouting, turned
into pushing and shoving,
turned into fistfights,
turned into riots.
Parisian police
actually storm in,
separate out the two parties.
And then on with the show.
I have no idea why.
Brief intermission, and
then on with the show.
Same thing happens.
Stravinsky, himself,
actually fled
the theater, feared
for his life,
never got to see the
curtain close on what
would become his
most famous piece.
History is filled
with great ideas.
They get rejected.
They get rejected all the time.
There are the
literal mousetraps,
and there are
metaphorical mousetraps.
What's happening is that for
an idea to be innovative,
for it to be a
disruptive innovation,
for it to be a great
idea, it has to be new
and it has to be useful.
And it turns out we're really
bad at reconciling those two
things.
Because if something
is new, by definition,
it diverts from the status quo.
But if something we
want to judge is useful,
what do we rely on to
judge whether or not
something is useful?
Status quo, older ideas,
our past expertise.
This is that
expertise myth, sort
of all over again, but
on a societal level.
And what you get, what we
find in research, especially
in times of uncertainty and
in situations of uncertainty,
we may say we love new ideas.
But we will always
cling to the comfort
of what appears to be useful.
And so on the surface we
say, I hear this all the time
from organizations.
You can title a book about how
companies generate great ideas.
And people read it.
Then you give them
this last chapter,
mousetrap myth thing
about, it's not actually
about generating great ideas.
Odds are your people
are already doing that.
It's about how bad we
all are at recognizing
the great ideas
that are coming out.
And there are a bunch
of different tools
that you can use.
So there are companies that
have internal stock markets.
And there are other
companies that
allow for a little,
sort of, hackathons.
There are other companies that
allow for sort of a burn fund.
We know we can lose this
much money on new stuff
and we'll just write it off.
And I don't want to talk
about the techniques
because the
techniques are great,
but unless we actually talk
about the psychological bias we
all have against great ideas.
It's sort of like an
Alcoholics Anonymous.
Call it Creatives Anonymous.
Hi I'm Dave and I have a
bias against great new ideas.
And until you actually
become aware of that bias,
and when you're presented
with a new idea--
even if it's something small--
until you become aware of it
and you realize that I am
evaluating this idea based
on my past experiences and that
might not be the right thing.
Until you come to that we
run into a big problem.
See I talked earlier about, you
have a Kindergarten classroom.
25 kids, they're all creative.
They get to college,
two of them are.
And even they're cheating.
So what is it that
happens in those years?
It's not necessarily
the education system.
We can tweak the education
system all we want.
It's that we as
people, when we're
evaluating the ideas of
these kids who are coming up,
we are suffering this bias.
And they get a new
idea that doesn't
jive with our status quo.
And we say, that's
a terrible idea.
Maybe it's a good idea.
Maybe it's a good idea
for where that person is.
And then we graduate into work.
And, by the way, it's not
all that different, right?
I used to get a report card.
Now I get a
performance evaluation.
It's the same system.
The letters changed.
That's about it.
The competencies might change.
I haven't had to solve
for x in a long time.
But that's because
of where I work.
So the competencies
change, but it's still
an evaluation system.
It's an evaluation
system based on this idea
that our old experiences
define what good looks like.
And when you present
a new idea that
doesn't jive with
our old experiences
it's not going to work,
until, of course, it does.
See the beautiful
thing that, the lesson
that I like to really
emphasize in the mousetrap myth
is that you all heard
"The Rite of Spring."
You all, presumably, have
used a personal computer,
another great idea that
got rejected at first.
You all have used
a digital camera.
That got rejected by the
people that developed it.
How may people have
been to Disneyland?
That was rejected
301 times for a loan.
Legend says.
I actually had a hard
time sourcing that.
But it's too good
to not be true.
So you all have presumably
been to Disneyland.
All of these great ideas
that are truly great
eventually persist.
And so I think the
best place to begin--
there's a much broader
long term discussion
we need to have about structure
and organizations in societies.
But the best place to begin is
if you've ever had a great idea
and it got rejected, take heart.
You're in really good company.
You're in the company
of Igor Stravinsky.
of Walt Disney.
You're in the company of people
who eventually did actually
arrive at that.
So take heart.
Know that they're doing that
with-- they had that bias.
They're suffering.
It's their problem.
But at the same time
realize this means
I need to work on mine too.
Because most of
the organizations
that I talk to start
with this idea of how do
we get more great ideas.
And for most of them the
truth is all the same.
We don't need more great ideas.
We just need to get
better at recognizing
the great ideas we already have.
We need to tell
ourselves that story.
We need to make sure
that that idea spreads.
So thank you so much.
I know we covered a ton of
different stuff in this.
And there's a lot of different
ideas to spread and myths
we need to rewrite.
But we also covered
a ton of stuff.
And I want to know what
questions do you have for me.
AUDIENCE: So is
this your next book?
Or how do we get
better at recognizing
the ideas that we've
already gotten?
DAVID BURKUS: So I talk
about a couple companies
that are really good at it.
My favorite in the
book is a company
called Right Solutions that
actually has an idea stock
market.
So you can basically
invest in virtual currency
and different ideas that people
post on this internal market.
And that doesn't
necessarily counteract
our psychological bias.
But it sort of spreads out
the pain of being wrong.
If I green light an idea and
it cost me 10 virtual dollars.
And it turns out to
be a terrible one,
I didn't lose much.
But as you think about
a traditional hierarchy
organization, the higher up
you go in an organization,
the more-- let's be honest--
the more your job is just
to not get fired.
You get to that top, top level.
And this is pretty sweet.
You think about-- the Fortune
500 list just came out.
Every Fortune 500 CEO is
like, this is a sweet gig.
I don't want to lose it.
So I don't want
to take big risks.
That's the sort of
psychological thing, I think,
that's behind much
more empirically proven
concepts like Clay Christensen's
"Innovator's Dilemma."
We're just trying
to not get fired.
In marketing there's a
saying that nobody ever
got fired for running
a Super Bowl ad.
It's good advice.
If you don't want to get fired.
If you want to do a
disruptive innovation,
you got to think a
little bit differently.
So it's actually not the next
book because I wish I knew.
I'm hoping to start a
much bigger conversation.
And maybe it's the third
book because there's
a lot more talk that
needs to happen.
I will say there is some
interesting work by Everett
Rogers.
He's actually the
guy that came up
with the diffusion
of innovation curve.
And he has some
interesting research
on-- there are five
factors that ideas,
that make it all the way
through that curve, all share.
And so it's kind of a good guide
of when you have this idea,
does it have these five things.
Well, then maybe I
should green light
even if it says it's crazy.
And so those things are,
is it easily try-able?
Even if it diverts
from the status quo
can you see the connection
between what you use to do
and what you do now?
Are the results
easily observable?
So can the improvement
be seen really easily
or does it take forever?
And I'm blanking
on the other two.
But they're there.
So Everett Rogers is the
author of these five factors.
I actually wrote a piece
about it for "99U."
And I'm blanking
on the other two.
But that's OK.
They're there.
Why bother to remember
when Google can tell me?
AUDIENCE: So in
the Amazon reviews
that I peeked at
shortly before coming--
DAVID BURKUS: Wow.
That's incredibly intimidating.
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's not bad.
No, I saw some stuff about
the creativity process
at Pixar that you
had written about.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
DAVID BURKUS: Yeah.
So I don't want to steal
too much of Ed's thunder.
Ed Catmull just
wrote an amazing book
called "Creativity, Inc." that's
his, for lack of a better term,
opening up the kimono and
saying here's how we do it.
And what's funny
is I tried really
hard to get more than what
had been previously written.
But because Ed was
working on that book
I didn't really want to talk
to somebody else writing
about their process.
But there's a lot that's
already readily shared.
And the thing that I
think is most telling,
the most useful thing
I think about when
I think about the
process of Pixar's, Ed
is fond of always saying
that every film at Pixar
sucks when its first
idea comes out.
And then they go
through a process
of going from suck to non-suck.
And presumably when it
non-sucks enough they ship it.
And that process is
actually using criticism.
So there's a chapter
in the book that I
call the cohesive myth, because
we have this idea that it
always works out happy
go lucky, free food, all
that sort of stuff.
And from an outside
perspective looking in,
you just feel like these
people never fight.
Well, at Pixar they
fight all the time.
They fight at these
things called dailies.
They're not personal fights.
But they are, I don't like
this about this frame.
And the thing that Pixar
does a lot of times
is they steal from improv.
Anybody ever taken
an improv class?
So first rule of improv,
always accept an offer.
I always say yes and--.
So they do this thing
called plussing,
where even if you're
criticizing you are building off
of that criticism
with a suggestion.
So Even if you're criticizing
you're still staying positive.
And when your complementing,
you're still building off of.
The idea is you're
criticizing people.
You're not doing the
compliment sandwich.
Has anybody ever eaten
a compliment sandwich?
They don't taste good.
You're not saying like,
here's an unrelated thing
you're good at.
Here's where you suck.
Here's an unrelated
thing you're good at.
But it's this part sucks.
And by the way, it's not you
suck, but this thing sucks.
And here's my idea to fix it.
And I accept or reject
that you can take it.
But I accept that if
I'm going to criticize
I have an obligation to give you
a suggestion to make it better.
Unfortunately I wrote
about this too much.
I don't like to share it
because then when I criticize,
people look back at me and go
well, you owe me a plus now.
You're under an obligation
to give me back it.
And sometimes I just
don't have them,
because we're really
good at criticizing.
But it takes time to really
get it into your head
that every time I'm going to
criticize something I also
have to offer a solution,
or a potential solution.
AUDIENCE: Have you witnessed
any meeting structures
or organization layouts,
they way they set up
the company, that
destroy creativity?
DAVID BURKUS: Hierarchy,
cubicles, lots of stuff.
No, I mean, a particular one?
I think one of the
really interesting things
is, I think what we have, and
this interestingly enough--
he ran off-- is the
subject of the next book.
At least for me, is I
think we have, in general,
a philosophy of management and a
philosophy of leadership that's
based on making a car, or making
some product in an assembly
line format.
And gradually, over time, some
more enlightened companies
with multi-colored logos
have come to the realization
that you can't use
that stuff over here.
But at a worldwide
level I don't think
we've gotten to
that awareness yet.
And even inside
of those companies
I don't know that they've
gotten to the idea
that we need to
think about building
systems around the needs and
the capabilities of people
and not of the product.
Because when you have a
knowledge work economy
your people are your product.
There's this phrase, our
people are our greatest asset.
You've heard it?
I hate that phrase.
I loathe it because assets
can be bought, sold.
Assets have systems to control
them, to leverage their value.
Your people are
your greatest source
of competitive advantage.
And that's a much
different approach
because that's not something
you can buy, sell, and trade
like a stock or a major
league baseball player.
Those people might be assets.
But normally our people are our
source of competitive advantage
or our source of ideas.
And any system that doesn't
start with the idea of here
are the people.
And now based on what
we know about the needs
and capabilities
of people, we'll
build the system around them.
I wish I could say this system
is bad and this one's great.
And everybody should do
holacracy or whatever
the current management fad is.
The point is to build a system
of management and leadership
around the needs of your
people, and then go from there.
And never be afraid to
tweak as those needs change,
because they will.
AUDIENCE: So at
the beginning you
mentioned society or
the environment that
might be encouraging creativity
or not or a lot of judgment.
So I wonder, like
Silcon Valley is
famous for a lot of projects,
exciting companies, and so on.
But what happened other places
that the culture is totally
the opposite.
How can you still succeed
in that kind of environment
or what suggestion do you have?
DAVID BURKUS: So we have
two layers to that question
if I may.
So there's the idea of what
about these other companies.
First of all, how
did that happen?
Some really interesting
research that basically
non-compete clauses
and some other stuff.
Essentially you
have this culture
of secrecy in a lot of places.
Like why did Silicon Valley
beat out Route 128 decades ago?
Well, one was about
keeping ideas secret,
very, very secret.
Other was about open
sharing of ideas.
There are always exceptions
that prove the rule.
One is not far from here.
The rest of them
are-- usually you
have the more your open
with sharing of ideas
around an organization
and the more tolerant
you are of those new ideas.
So what do you do
if you're stuck
in one, if you're
stuck on Route 128?
First of all you may
not be there for long.
I grew up not far from there.
I remember in Lowell,
Massachusetts there's
this massive building,
the Wang building.
And it was empty for years.
And it was a testament to
like, this doesn't work.
And I never forgot that.
I moved away fairly often
but I never forgot that idea.
You're smiling because
you've probably seen
the Wang building, right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right
off [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID BURKUS: Yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
So testament too that the
social environment matters.
So what do you do
if you stuck-- first
of all if you're stuck in
a company like that you
won't be there for long.
It'll fold up and you'll
go somewhere else.
The other thing,
I think, is a lot
of us don't appreciate that
we have this work life balance
approach of like it's
two different things,
and we need to balance the two
instead of integrate and merge
around.
And there are obviously
legal limits to how much
you're supposed to share.
My wife's an ER
doctor so there's
some stuff she's not
legally allowed to share.
But there's other things
that she comes home with
and we talk about.
And so I think if you're stuck
in a company that doesn't allow
that, find some
other way to at least
be in a social environment
that supports that,
even if you know it's not
going to work in your company.
And build an exit plan.
It's a sad thing.
But the fun thing.
There's a woman by the
name of Orly Lobel who's
done a lot of research on
talent that moves around,
non-compete clauses,
and that sort of stuff.
And she encapsulates this idea
that talent wants to be free.
Not free in the sense that they
don't want to work for anyone
and they just want
to be freelancers.
But they want to know that
when they have an idea
they're free to pursue it.
If they need to move to
a different organization,
if they need to share
it with people outside,
that they have freedom.
So if you are talent and you
want to be free and you're not,
get free.
Now if your an organization
and all your talent's leaving,
there's a lesson for you in
somebody else's book called
"Talent wants to be Free"
that will help you a lot.
But first, of course, read
the one with the monkey
on the cover.
AUDIENCE: You made a
comparison between Kindergarten
and college classes.
And I was wondering
if you've come
across any individuals
or any stories
about people who've
actually retained
the same level of
creativity they
had when they were
in kindergarten.
DAVID BURKUS: So
I like to bridge
the gap between what I
can empirically prove
and what I can turn
into a good story.
And in this case I can't.
But I can tell you that a lot
of people's stories or ideas
flow around.
This is, I think,
why we actually
associate certain disciplines
as creative and others as not.
So if you were that free spirit
that the traditional system is
kind of crushing,
there are places
where you find solace
and sanctuary, the art
classroom if it still exists
in your public school, theater,
music.
There are just
certain disciplines
where that environment is
there and so you naturally
gravitate towards it.
And because it supports
that you begin to practice.
And practice really does,
well deliberate practice,
really does make perfect.
So I think, one
specific story, no.
But I think the reason
people gravitate
towards certain fields
sometimes is just that.
They feel like they have this
desire to express themselves
and they find
sanctuary somewhere.
As a story on a personal note
that sort of resonates with me.
I have two siblings.
One is a musician.
The other's in music theater.
And I'm a writer.
And all three of us were sort
of attracted to that early on.
All three of us did terribly
in the school systems
until we arrived at
that place of study
where we could actually
do what we wanted to do
and then thrived.
So it happens.
AUDIENCE: The talk it out.
I'm kind of curious about
the idea of the 2.6.
I feel like the
inverse U of how if you
have too much kind of difference
or too much unity like those
could be kind of
limiting factors.
And I'm curious whether you
have any thoughts on how
either companies or things
should structure themselves
according to that.
Because in the
political system you've
got political parties
switching in and out.
There's elections so you
can get new people in,
old people out and
stuff like that.
Do you feel like companies--
DAVID BURKUS: That'd
be ideal but I
don't know that that happens.
So what you have is
you have your party
that's in and then when they're
voted out they'll move over
to this think tank and they
wait for another cycle.
And they all come back in.
So you don't get the 2.6.
I mean I would love
for that to happen.
There is, interestingly
enough, from right here,
it started in San Francisco.
There's an awesome nonprofit
called Fuse Corps that actually
works to sort of
build 2.6 teams.
What they essentially do
is they place fellows.
They hate when I use this
analogy but it works.
They're sort of like
Teach for America
but for city and
state governments.
So they try and place mid-career
professionals and entrepreneurs
into city and state
governments in order
to bring those fresh ideas in.
The other thing I think a
lot of industrial design
and consulting firms
have a structure
that allows them to do that.
Roger Martin from the Rotman
School up in Toronto actually
had this great article a couple
months ago in the Harvard
Business Review around,
even economically there
may be a case for the
consultancy firm model,
where people are always moving
around to different projects.
Because when you have an
economic downturn, if you've
structured boxes and lines in
a traditional hierarchy then
you look and go, this
segment's not performing.
We spit it off.
But if you have a much more
fluid structure than you
can adapt quicker and possibly
not lay as many people off
and then have to scramble
to find new people when
it comes back.
That's where it sucks.
So there's maybe
even an economic case
to be made for that
little bit more fluid.
We're really at the
beginning of figuring out
what does this model look
like, because it doesn't look
like boxes and lines and
factory assembly lines
and that sort of stuff.
AUDIENCE: So some of the stuff
you talked about reminded me
of The Smart Stranger,
which I think
you kind of started
to allude to.
But this idea that
someone who's smart--
the mathematician that
you were talking about.
DAVID BURKUS: Paul Erdos.
AUDIENCE: Erdos.
OK.
So he was--
DAVID BURKUS: Our only
mathematician already left.
Shame.
AUDIENCE: Like he was playing
the role of the smart stranger
where you're a smart
person and then
you jump into an environment
that you're not familiar with.
And that that actually sparks
innovation and creativity.
Since it sounds like you're
also in business school
stuff probably?
So is anyone looking
at the opportunities
of formalizing a smart
stranger as like a role,
almost, in companies
to spark innovation?
This is like kind of wild, but--
DAVID BURKUS: What?
AUDIENCE: Like 20% of the
time it's kind of like that.
DAVID BURKUS:
Similar in the idea
you play around with
something you're new at.
I think you're talking
about a deliberate role.
Almost like you have a devil's
advocate for criticism.
You have the smart
stranger for like-- I'm
really hesitant
because obviously this
is being recorded and
will be world wide
and I want to pretend like this
is our idea and trademark it.
And then we'll spin it off.
But it's actually
a really good idea.
AUDIENCE: We'll talk later.
DAVID BURKUS: Yeah, for sure.
It's actually a really
good idea in a formal role.
I don't know of anything.
One of the things
I love again, this
comes out of Roger Martin
again and Michael Porter
and the consulting group
that they started years
ago in strategy.
One of the really
common questions
that doesn't get asked often
enough when you're building
a strategy, is what assumptions
have to be true for this
to work?
And really just
taking the deliberate,
did we remember to
ask that question.
Because even that's
like OK, let's
assume all of our assumptions
are wrong and then prove them.
Some of them may not be true.
And so you can arrive at that
same sort of expertise thing.
I think the other thing, the
thing that we especially-- I'm
an American so I'm
terrible at-- is just
stop pretending to be
an expert in everything.
I think it's really interesting.
I walk in sometimes to
organizations or conferences.
And we do a prep call.
And sometimes I've researched
them and other times I haven't.
Mostly just ran out of time.
And I used to like pretend
that I had researched them.
Now I'm on Wikipedia
while I'm on the phone.
But this amazing thing
happened when I said,
no, I really don't know
much about your company.
Tell me about it.
And it's amazing because when
you sort of swallow your pride
that you don't know
everything, they'll
tell you the stuff
that isn't necessarily
factual but the stuff you
actually need to know.
So this is an amazing thing that
can happen when you just go,
no I'm sorry.
I tried.
I didn't have the time.
Tell me about it.
You don't even have to say,
tell me what's important to you.
They just will.
So it's, yeah, smart
stranger thing.
I really need to go to a
trademark search on that.
We'll talk.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But thank
you so much for your time
and we've really
enjoyed hosting you.
DAVID BURKUS: Thank you.